-I know one thing you do
in your down time,
which was very sweet of you.
Last time you were here,
my son Axel had just been born
and you knitted
this wonderful hat for him
-I did.
-That is just incredible.
And it was --
His noggin is so big.
It, like, basically fit hi
for like a day and a half.
But he was so warm.
But I am glad that you found
other people to make
your beautiful hats for.
This is your cat, yeah?
-That is my cat.
[ Laughter ]
Coco. She --
I forced the hat upon her.
-I'm very surprised --
I mean, Coco seems okay with it,
which I'm shocked that a cat
would be okay with this.
-I mean, she's tolerant.
-Uh-huh.
-But I feel like
that's her general personality
-Isn't that -- Yeah,
that's the height of any cat
That's the highest grade.
-Yeah.
-That's five stars for a cat
is tolerance.
-You know, I'll take it.
-Last time you were here,
you were doing "Deadpool."
And we were talking
about the fact that being
in a comic-book movie
was very --
A lot of credit, a lot of
cachet, I should say, with -
You have German cousins.
You have a younger brother
And now you're
in the "Joker" movie.
Is it helping again?
Is this even giving you
more cred with them?
-Um, absolutely. I think -
I just recently saw my cousins
in Germany,
and they wanted me to sign stuff
and blah, blah, blah.
And I'm, like "I'm your family."
-Yeah.
-Um, but, no. It's great.
I think the familial validation,
you know, it matters most.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-I'm glad to have it.
-It is funny. I'm realizing no
not one of my cousins
has ever asked for my autograph.
-Really?
-I'm kind of heartbroken.
I also thought it was weird.
Nothing.
-Not your tears, your blood.
Nothing?
-Nothing. You --
It's a beautifully acted film.
Obviously,
you're fantastic in it.
Joaquin Phoenix
is transformative.
His body is -- I'm happy
you did not have to do that.
-Yeah.
-And I read he ate
an apple a day.
-Yeah.
-Was that then weird
when you had sort of
a lunch break for everybod
that you were --
You guys were eating human meals
and he was --
-He usually disappeared
during lunch,
but on set we always have
something called Crafty,
which is just food available
for everyone else
because you're around
for 12 hours a day.
And I was pretty unabashedly
kind of eating my way
through the day.
But he would
sometimes cheat, too,
and have like three pretzels
-Yeah.
-Then run off.
-There was a scene
where he looked a little flabby,
and I thought
that was probably pretzel day.
-That was pretzel day for sure
-Then the Joker got real chubb
in this one scene.
You also worked
with Natalie Portman
in a film that's coming ou
called "Lucy in the Sky."
This is based on a true stor
about astronauts.
So you got to be an astronaut.
-Yeah, I did. Yes.
-Did you enjoy putting on
the astronaut costume?
Was that something
that you found exciting?
-Yeah, I think what's nice
about being an actor is, like,
I feel, like there are all these
career doors that have close
for me, like being an athlet
or an astronaut.
And it's really fun
to kind of put on somethin
and be, like "Oh, yeah.
I have the cred
and, you know,
the intelligence to be here.
But it is fun to play in that,
and that is something that
like, draws me to performing
is I get to play all these
other versions of myself.
-And it's true,
because the other path
to wearing an astronaut outfit
is like 20 years of training
I feel like.
-Yeah.
-And for you to just get cast,
I mean, you really cut the line.
-I know. Yeah.
-And then "Atlanta."
You guys are going
back to work there.
Is that exciting?
-Yeah, I'm really
looking forward to that.
I think that show, to me,
feels so much like a homecomin
or like a family thing,
I think, in a way
'cause we all really
found footing in our careers
on that show
and feel sort of like
this safe place,
and so, you know,
I'm really looking forward
to going back and doing that
-How long of a break
will it have been
between the last time
you guys were on set together?
-My God. We were on set together
end of 2017.
-Oh, wow. Really?
-So almost -- almost two years
-That's really great,
and it's nice --
I mean, I feel, like that show
is in such safe hands
based on the quality,
the level of quality
and consistency of it,
so it's nice to know
that it will come back.
And I think there are sometime
shows where you worry
about a layoff, and that's one
where I have no worries at all
-Ah, thank you. We have a lovely
group chat going on, so...
I think, you know,
the energy is still there
and everybody
is excited to go back.
-That's great. Well, it's always
so lovely to have you here
Congratulations on everything.
Zazie Beetz, everybody.